what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch our
final set of Ant-Man trailers I just
dropped them all in the Final Cut we're
gonna watch before experience an Emerald
City John how are you I am very much
anticipating these spots you wasp sounds
racist
change a couple letters there anyway
guys I want to give a quick mention too
by the way we're almost at full capacity
here if you haven't caught the memo yet
John can be a Christian harloff and I
are doing a live event at Flappers in
Burbank California Sunday February 19th
at 9pm what inspired this the weekend of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania so we
wanted to talk about that q a whatever
other hijinks might occur Christian
Hall's gonna be doing some stand-up
comedy beforehand if you are in the LA
area or are visiting would love for you
to come attend yeah of course love to
talk to you after the show as well but
don't look campy in the eyes they'll
kick you uh let's get to it guys
foreign
[Music]
you're an interesting man
Scotland you have a daughter
that's interesting you're an Avenger you
read my book
nice I killed you before but they just
spoil that on February 17th I can
shattered existence nothing can prepare
you you may not want her to watch this
for the new Dynasty
experience it in 3D February 17th
Scotland you're an Avenger
wow wow you're out of your league that's
Power sword kind of shatter timelines
everything you call a life will end and
you're not getting out
I think he will yeah man but nice try we
both just have to lose Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum media ready PG-13 February
17th get tickets now a lot has changed
about my life
we literally saved the world literally
but right now the only job I want is
being a dad
Scotland
do you want to get out cool so beautiful
and I need to get out of here
what's that oh
I cannot trust him
we'll see I don't care who this guy is I
just lost so much time
[Music]
risk it all Scott who thinks he's a God
everything you call a life
this guy Cassie we'll stop him together
you think you can beat me
Ant-Man and a wasp quantumia rated PG-13
in theaters February 17 get tickets now
ah dope love excited love it can't wait
to can't wait to review this movie looks
so exciting guys there's a lot of good
tidbits in here a lot of good expansions
on some other moments that we've already
seen prior I guess it was that one
moment where you know like I like that
moment where he's you know giant man
form and he goes crying but when he
knocks over that building and the blue
smoke
um disperses from there I was like wait
a minute is that like kings tower that
they're revealing he's just knocking
over because why is he specifically
targeting that Tower yeah you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah cause I've been avoiding
leaks on this movie
um I'm very very excited for I've been
reading a lot of Kane Comics as of late
a lot of my late nights before I go to
bed it's been a lot of King and so far I
feel like from the little glimpses that
we've been getting you know Jonathan
majors has especially been embodying
everything about that I enjoy reading
with Ken because he's a very you know uh
poetic type of individual and thinks
very highly of himself and I I like that
but he's also like a sad guy you know
like deep down underneath he's sad and
there's a lot of big hardened shell of a
lot of pain and hurt where a lot of this
uh aggression and focus towards
depending on the run that you read but a
lot of the stuff that I've been reading
at least a lot of the the goal of
conquering and stuff you know like we've
had ravona rentslayer be brought into
the Loki season 2 show and that is such
an integral part of King's life and I
imagine that if you're introducing he
who remains within you know uh Loki
season two that yeah there has been any
hints towards her here but you know
there are certain runs where it a big
part of the focus is getting to rivona
so I I feel like though might they might
bring it back to that because they are
emphasizing the dynasty angle here
within the the marketing so I'm I'm
least curious to see how it goes because
yeah I mean the big talk about this
movie is King itself but what I really
also enjoyed about these spots in
particular is just the expansion of the
the cosmic not even caught I don't even
call it the quantum battles that you're
going to be getting yeah the quantum
battles that you're getting here uh just
look like they're gonna be
wild and I I didn't even really quite go
there when thinking of the the level of
Destruction and Chaos within the quantum
realm itself that we are going to be
witnessing as this film has probably
some insane Crescendo that will be
perhaps Bleak and not as uh optimistic
and as I was getting these dark endings
okay well I mean you look at him here
and like that one shot of him like
screaming where his face is like his
lips are like drained of color and he
looks like so just battle worn yeah like
they're really gonna throw him through
the ringer in this movie and two I mean
even though what they're leading with is
mostly the spectacle and mostly the you
know wild nature of the quantum realm
the mind-bending nature I do Wonder
because there isn't an aspect of this
that is you know Kang needs a McGuffin
of some sort uh I wonder a if they'll
bring back some of those Heist flavors
that they uh you know obviously that
Mark the Ant-Man series but also if I
mean some people have speculated that
maybe here what it will be is that Kang
doesn't need like a piece apart it is
maybe ravona that he's going to try and
you know secure to you know help pop off
his main plan or something like that so
like I don't know I feel like the
interconnectivity that we were craving
for for phase four is like primed to pop
off in this place because you have Loki
season two coming probably in the summer
time and uh you know this like
chronopolis as they've realized it here
has so many just stylistic and aesthetic
similarities to like the TVA and things
like that which was you know spun by a
different Kang and so yeah I I feel like
we could have more of that universe's
crossover than we're even expecting from
this not that I want like the Ant-Man
movie has been kind of great because
they haven't focused too heavily on
crossover and a bunch of extra stuff
coming in
um but you know they have said that this
is going to be like a very significant
it seems like they want this to be the
most significant Ant-Man movie so aside
from all the personal stuff with Cassie
and everything thing like I I I'm
getting the sense with how scopic and
huge these trailers are that they
probably will bleed into and feel very
consequential to the rest of the
universe at hand along with how you're
like Bill Murray and Modoc and like you
know fun uh Side characters to bring in
and stuff like that and yeah like I love
the anger like the seething anger that
reads off of Kang the Conqueror here
because he remains does have like such a
bubbly personality but you can feel that
sadness that pathos underneath and here
it seems like all that bubbliness has
just been replaced with a rage and I
love the tones of the performance
they're putting here because yeah he's
talking so soft but when you really see
him he is like overflowing with anger
and I feel like that could create a
really cool tension for that character
just as a performance yeah there's a lot
to grasp on to here people can't wait
social media reactions left on Tuesday
let's see what everyone has to say you
know they're all going to be [__] they
always go even when a movie's bad it's
always [__] you can't buy I asked with
you free screenings yeah
alrighty guys well leave your thoughts
down below and what you're most looking
forward to about Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania uh subscribe keep a look
out for our review last but not least
I'll send us for the
Doran ah man I would love to go to the
quantum realm with you sir because no
matter what the threats would be you
would have uh you know a way to lift all
of our Spirits I feel like you would be
the prime stand-in for an Ant-Man at the
reject Nation you're Plucky you're
good-natured maybe sometimes a little
down on your luck or whatever but you
never let that get to you flev and every
time I see you you know even in text
form you just you just make me want to
smile you know you just bring me Good
Vibes you were like Good Vibes incarnate
the person and uh and we know you love
Marvel and I bet you're excited I wish
we could bring you with us that's the
ultimate goal is one day we all need to
watch a Marvel like a fresh new Marvel
movie in the theaters together that's
what I hope happens so uh you know
however whatever Time Heist DEH hijinks
we need to do to secure that let's make
it happen flev let's do it Flav coming
to California and sit in front of us and
be on your phone all day yeah at the
movie and get us kicked out we'll talk
with you soon buddy
[Music]